do you feel like um because there was
like this big discussion which I didn't
think was necessarily a fair one I
understood what did he was doing because
I think Diddy is an r b head and did
he's also working on r b album so I
understand why he said r b was dead but
I mean obviously I don't agree with him
I don't even think he might all the way
agree with himself on that but do you
feel like R B's finally kind of because
now when I listen to the radio
or I play songs on the radio yeah right
but like you know I think of a song last
year like money Long's record is like a
that's a real r b record that like went
top 40 that went like Rhythm like that
to me like is like a sign of like okay
like R B's kind of coming back in terms
of like it being more popular music not
to say it's ever gone anywhere you mean
that yeah the actual popularity of it
there's so many different
styles of r b there is there's like sub
genres of r b sub genres and I don't
think it's ever really died I think like
you said it's just what's what became
popular it's like I mean it's super cool
too right the the the playlists and the
radios were more condensed yeah so you
had everything kind of planned in the
same spaces you know what I'm saying but
then as as the digital Crusade happened
earlier when you start to
compartmentalize things now you put this
in this compartment it makes it easier
to for one genre to stand in front right
so but also it's a lot more hip-hop
being you know what I'm saying pushed
but it I think a lot of the conversation
about r b being dead was just to create
dialogue I think that's what it was I
think that's like I think that's really
what Jesus is doing and it worked and
I'm happy he did that you know what I'm
saying he's a pioneer he's a goat in
this [__] so who better to do it if you
had to make an r b super group with two
other singers who would you put in your
super group one album your teeth what
was it TGT
crazy
um
bro
that's crazy like I had to say usher and
CB oh
I mean that's that's crazy yeah I'm
gonna have to say that this is like I
mean yeah that's those are the two right
answers we say r b and then like
Generations like I feel like
that's like Usher's gonna grab a little
bit older than me yeah CB's gonna grab
mine and younger and then I'm like in
the middle grabbing it you know what I'm
saying but this detection the voice text
phone in the jail verse from R Kelly
yeah Hey listen I ain't gonna lie to you
I bump his [__] every [__] day me too
every [__] day
listen I am not ashamed to say I can
separate the art from the art it comes
to an artist who has been able to make
every type of song and have every type
of have fun or baby man come on man I
believe I can fly to half on a baby to
you know
it's just he's just the goat he's the
guy but you know listen it's him a
rusher because I went to Usher show in
Vegas have you seen his Vegas show of
course I'm just talking about but you
can't compare them to bro
you can't compare Usher and R Kelly in
terms of being the ghost of R B Because
all right Kelly his pin
I agree Kelly's got the greatest pen
ever probably he wrote for Michael
Jackson like
baby making songs
pop records like a big wreck like but
you know what you know what R Kelly
never got though I don't know
he never got like a OMG he didn't really
participate in that but he can't come
out in that time no but I was gonna
because but think about it right well
listen I mean Usher came out in 94 no
but but
R Kelly was not he was not incarcerated
in 2010 when every R B artist was doing
shitty EDM songs do you remember that
era right absolutely that don't count
that's cheat code [__] I don't think it
counts like when Neo and Pitbull were
put out of I can't world you can't have
the r b conversation at that point
that's out
so listen I agree with you for this I
think R Kelly's the greatest of all time
I think when you factor in everything
okay
he gave me my flowers at the show I just
think Usher is like a like amazing not
only is he got the classics but he also
the entertainment because like I've seen
R Kelly live when I was a little kid I
saw him and not I saw him in Nas and it
was great that's different I don't know
I think but it was like categorize it I
feel like R Kelly was more like he was
like more like when you watched him live
it was like kind of like watching a
rapper he had background dances right
like Usher as a performer no we're not
talking [__] skates bro Chris Brown's
out here a superstar he's a performer
he's like a he's a pop r b he's an r b
Superstar what are we talking about just
R B music I have to Crown R Kelly I have
to I respect that and and I agree
and there's a lot I mean there's so many
great artists man I think it's crazy I
think the three names that I I mean and
this is just speaking of somebody who
was born in 1987 but then you got a
crown CB2 listen I was gonna say the
three Chris Brown ushering R Kelly yeah
you got a crowd CB man like he he's an
Elio I think he's the most alien
talented artist yeah he him ever I think
it's him and it's Jamie Foxx because I'm
just thinking Talent I'm not talking
about music I just mean
Talent inside of a human being yeah for
sure Chris Brown can paint a mural on a
building
he can dance maybe all-time great dancer
him and Michael Jackson he could sing he
could write he could wrap his ass off he
could act ish oh you know he was all
right and then he could hoop he could I
mean I mean listen then there's Jamie
Foxx who can do all that and he's one of
the greatest stand-up comedians of all
time yeah man he's one of the greatest
actors ever like it's a lot of it's a
lot of talent and in our culture bro
it's a lot of talent it's crazy